today on stick to football we were
breaking down college football week six
yes we are at week six and god that is
depressing it is fall finally in
Missouri Connor still rocking the hoodie
you would know that if you're watching
this on YouTube bleach reports YouTube
channel look for the stick to football
playlist welcome to the Friday show
mellow and I kind of matched today we
are basic white boys today with our
flannel on I got my pumpkin spice latte
over on the side from some coffee place
that we won't mention did your did your
guys mom dress you the same morning we
did today oh no because one we were poor
and two we were the same size so Melo
just stole my clothes
no separate dressers at the Miller
household it was just who wants to wear
which shirt exactly yeah today's my day
to wear it we do have some updates for
you guys before we get into what's gonna
be a really fun show our Kansas City
tailgate we're just a couple days away
October 6th lot J we will be taking over
lot J at 3 p.m.
operation BBQ will be there are friends
from mid-america RV we're gonna have the
tailgate RV there like we had at Ohio
State Michigan it's gonna be a great
time come out party with us there
there's gonna be food there's we drinks
we're gonna be recording the podcast
live from there and the lot J crew they
are I didn't know this they are
legendary there's me several hundred
people showing up to this thing that
they're like a big family that tailgates
together every week so that's gonna be a
blast and we now have details for our
Dallas Texas tailgate event we're gonna
be taking over off-the-cuff which is in
Deep Ellum it's right across the street
from Fair Park basically so if you want
to go to the game you'll be close enough
we'll be taking over they're actually
opening early for us so 9 a.m. we're
gonna be in there probably doing boozy
breakfast recording the podcast and then
we'll stay there to watch Texas get
their ass kicked by oh you that's what
we have going am it's like that huh it's
gonna happen I'm I'm worried I'm really
looking forward to our next two
tailgates sometimes we get back from the
road and it's like oh my god I have to
go back out but going to Kansas City
pretty short trip for us and I'm really
looking forward to the lot J and
everything that they have to offer there
the high temperatures
like 66 okay which is perfect it's
supposed to hold off on the rain very
very excited about that tailgate and
then the Texas owe you one we'll get to
see Andrew Magnussen again I guess
that's all I have excited to see mags
and Tyler about it yeah tell Gator of
the year mags my goodness he is he's
racking him up so get on his level
moving on from the tailgate tour which
has been crazy and I know a lot of
people also been asking about London
plans we're gonna have those locked in
for all you guys next week we'll make
the announcement of where we'll be in
London that weekend so a lot going on
with the tailgate tour the Jaguars say
they won't trade Jalen Ramsay I think
this is a good move I know you guys
might be sitting over there and a little
disappointed that maybe the Chiefs will
get in on the action but when it comes
down to it this is a team competing
right now and I think this is a
franchise kind of player do you think
this relationship can be repaired I
don't and I know we've talked a lot
about this on the show before I love one
of you guys said you know like money
fixes everything let me tell you from
some previous relationships it doesn't
fix everything it makes things more
complicated sometimes I think that
Ramsey I mean he's still not practicing
so it's not like they're saying oh we
won't trade you and he's like okay well
let me just come back then a play for
you he's still not there I actually
don't know did the kid get born you know
he missed the game because like for the
birth of his child I never saw Bertha
now ever heard of it I don't know I
don't know if there's a kid or not isn't
that weird though you would expect like
something I haven't seen I haven't seen
a kid yet maybe we're living in a bubble
here and we just haven't seen the birth
announcement on Instagram but I don't
think that it's gonna fix itself
I really don't when a player says I want
traded and then he has been injured or
absent ever since I feel like they're
getting to a point where and I actually
wrote about this for Scouting notebook
tomorrow and I'll steal my own content
tell you what I said jaylen Ramsey is
under roster controlled for seven years
if the Jacksonville Jaguars want him to
be they have a fifth year option and
they can franchise him twice this is his
chance to get out of town if he wants to
so this is it this is his shot and if he
really wants out if it's really a broken
relationship he has to stick to his plan
here yeah I agree with you I
I do think that money can fix most
things he might not come back and say I
love in being in Jacksonville but I do
think that they could throw money his
way and get him to stay because he is
under roster control for a long time and
when the owners coming out and just
blatantly saying we're not trading this
guy
I believe him I don't think he's
bluffing here if he really wanted to
move him I think he would so we'll see
what happens with Jalen Ramsey if I were
betting on it today I think that he will
suit up for the Jaguars again this
season especially with the way that
they're playing name it might be a
playoff team and I just don't see Jalen
Ramsey being the competitor that he is
sitting out playoff games I don't think
this is gonna be an a/b situation where
he's you know chucking up the deuces on
week 17 and standing on the sidelines
for a half of a game yeah maybe he has
hopes he goes through a team like Kansas
City or like the Eagles I think
Jacksonville ideally would trade him out
of the conference but listen if Gardner
Minshew keeps leading them to wins at
what point are you just like hey this
team's winning right now I'm gonna come
back I'm gonna worry about me and then
we'll worry about this in the offseason
hopefully they can get to a point where
that's the solution rather than if
you're Jacksonville right now why do you
want to big is his market right now
there's only so many teams that are
willing to give away first-round picks
and the contract situation and hit the
cost for him is gigantic and I think
there's been all the rumors around the
Eagles cuz they need corner help and
they are believed to be a contender but
at the end of the day this is probably
not the ideal time to trade him if
you're Jacksonville especially when the
owner shad Kahn comes down since we
don't want to trade him let's move on
though to the quarterback position in
Jacksonville I think this is a really
interesting question for what we do here
at stick to football if you guys if if
Tom Coughlin steps aside and says Mello
and Connor we want you to come around
the team you have to make a decision
very soon on Nick Foles or Gardner
Minshew Nick Foles was the prize of free
agency they signed him to a starting
quarterback deal but then you get
Gardner Minshew who has been red-hot but
Nick Foles signed a four-year 88 million
dollar contract what do you guys do
moving forward at the quarterback
position I already know what I would do
and I think you guys know what I would
but I'm interested to hear your take on
this I don't think you do have to move
on from Nick Foles though I think you
let Minshew play out this season and see
if he can kind of ride this train and
keep up what he's doing and if he can
then alright maybe he's our starting
quarterback a la the Seattle Seahawks
when they paid all that money to Matt
Flynn and then went and drafted Russell
Wilson he won the job he was the better
quarterback that's working out for him
okay now that big contract is gonna be
hard to move if you're Nick Foles maybe
at the end of the year you explore teams
with like Cincinnati or you see who
wants to come and offer you something
for him but if gardner minshew is
getting the job done you drafted him in
the sixth round that's a low dollar sign
there that's one dollar sign on Yelp is
what you're getting gonna mention four
so I think you stay with that for a
while and see if you can build around
him as long as he is playing well the
second I think that it starts to go bad
then you're probably gonna want to hold
on to Nick Foles he's been a good
reliable backup in the past so if you
need him he can come right back in and
take you to man he is eligible to return
week 11 so they might have a decision to
make in a couple weeks as opposed to
when the season's over Connor how do you
play this thing you ride the hot hands
but I don't know if that handles still
be hot that far down the road from now
I'm excited about Gardner Minshew
I hope that we were wrong and
undervalued him we're gonna talk about
our top five rookies later on in the
show and where we had them projected but
if he's playing like this you'd roll
with Gardner Minshew
now it's interesting I know matt is on
the trade everyone bandwagon so but like
Melo said I'm looking at this contract
right now fifty million dollars
guaranteed of course a significant
portion of those guarantees are tied
into the next two years I don't really
know who is willing to take on this
contract right now that's my biggest
question and I think at the end of the
day they might be excited Nick Foles is
back and you know at that point of the
season I don't want to write I think
Gardner's been great we have to see it
keep going yeah I will say I think Nick
Foles you can get out of that contract
after the 2020 season I believe so
there's a potential out and like Melo
said you got that one dollar sign on
Gardner Minshew review you can look at
this as okay how much we paying our
quarterback
room it's still very manageable I just
don't know that Nick Foles is gonna be
happy once again being replaced of being
the backup I am team trade almost
everyone to win in the NFL to build a
team you need a rookie quarterback
contract or you need someone like Tom
Brady whose wife is a Brazilian
supermodel and is willing to take
significantly less than his market value
to build the team around we're taking
money under the table fro that's the
more like one or two or the deck
prescott side of things where it's hey
it you make more money being the
quarterback of the Cowboys so we're
gonna give you a discounted deal i
whatever it takes you got to get the
deal done if I would rather have Gardner
mentioned in Nick Foles he's already
looked better than Nick Foles can we
could we admit that that Nick Foles
looked which version yeah any of them I
mean other than the Chip Kelly year
where he was like 27 and to the CEO one
was decent I do think that you're right
and we've talked about this a million
times
being able to build a team around a
rookie contract is a lot better and if
you're looking at your quarterback room
and your allotting so many dollars
you're probably still set up okay you're
happy with a sixth-round quarterback and
a guy who's making 88 million over the
next four years you can build around
that but I do think that if you're gonna
keep a guy like
Jalen Ramsay around and if you can get
somebody to come in and and take Nick
Foles off your hands then okay let's
wash our hands of that deal we have our
quarterback in place but also like
Connor said it's been four games let's
see what we have with Gardner Minshew
before we build our future and plan
around him at passer rating and through
four games is there like a record high
though it's impressive I against for
good deep kind of for good defense it's
Kansas leading really good houston
tennessee and denver pretty decent
defenses that he seen so far so maybe it
is real maybe I was wrong about Gardner
we'll we'll find out yeah we'll get to
the next in two segments actually all
right sake well Barkley continues to
defy the odds I don't understand genetic
Lee how this is a real human being
high ankle sprain two weeks ago today
he's the walking boot is gone number one
which I don't know how that's even
possible and then he's out running
around cutting his sake on actually
gonna
and secondarily should he play that's
the key that's where I actually get hung
up I don't have him on into my fantasy
team so I'm not like rooting for oh I
need the points the Giants are two and
two they're one game back basically in
the NFC East which I don't think anybody
thought they were gonna be there do you
place a call Barclay this early I do
risk their one without him last night I
don't know if you risk it
I would probably hold him out this week
from what I've seen in practice he looks
pretty damn good jumping around and I
mean he's moving very well you could you
couldn't tell he was injured but I
thought I would play it cautiously this
week and say we're gonna keep you
limited I know that you look great
you're running around in practice I
would hold him out from this game and if
he's still performing well he still
feels great then I'd play him next week
but this week I wouldn't even make it an
option I have the Vikings this week he
was supposed to be out like what six to
eight weeks it's been one yeah he said
he missed one week so I would probably
sit him this week just to be cautious
this is one of the best runningback
prospects Matt you've ever seen I think
you want to play it a little bit safe
early in his career especially when you
you're kind of having a rebuild
situation here I know that your
quarterbacks winning you all kinds of
ballgames now but I would probably hold
say Quan back this week or maybe even it
at the minimum you're limiting his
touches yeah they definitely should hold
him back a high ankle sprain I mean the
this is one of the easiest injuries to
reactivate or make way worse that's the
problem with the high ankle sprain but
say Quan is different it looks like he's
moving around pretty well and I wouldn't
be shocked if he suits up at least like
Melo said limited touches kind of roll
I'm sure the coaching staff does not
look at it as a rebuilding year they
want to win with Daniel Jones right now
that Minnesota defense is a really
really good group so they know they need
him in this game I would not be shocked
if he plays I really would not be
shocked it's crazy if you asked me that
a week ago I'd been like hell no but I
think just watching him move around even
in that short clip out it's like wow
he's doing everything he can to be ready
for the game
one last nugget before we get to our
blind review the Vikings wide receivers
are pissed they they're not next to find
miss practice Wednesday then he's
interviewed on Thursday and he's like
yeah the rumors are true they stated
there's rumors right Adam feelings like
you can't win if you can't throw the
ball both players have seen their
targets significantly reduced this year
they're just not throwing the ball very
much I think you can even look at the
stats like Kirk Cousins his attempts are
incredibly low this year number one
Conor your Jets dodged a [ __ ] bullet
by not signing my guy that totally
guaranteed contract they wanted to hear
secondarily he has regressed to a point
that it's actually staggering to me how
bad he is looking and he was always
inconsistent here we go through waves of
looking great and then waves of looking
absolutely terrible I think that's where
we're at
he has three touchdowns and two
interceptions this year that is a
starting quarterback in the NFL a lot of
guarantee hook in the backfield it's
unbelievable to me
so only 99 passes attempted attempted
this year again through four games
that's astronomically low I think they
have a problem at quarterback in
Minnesota I think that's safe to say and
you look at the way Dalvin coaches
played you have probably the best
receiver duo in the league they're just
missing a quarterback here the offensive
line has played much better this year
the defense is still great they're
missing a quarterback they tried to do
it via free agency but I'll tell you
before we get to the spring and all this
stuff happens again there's a reason why
these guys hit free agency right now
there's another team didn't want them so
I think that's what's happening with the
Vikings I do think that they're gonna be
a team that is really after quarterbacks
this year in the draft I mean Luke Falk
has a higher QPR than Kirk Cousins right
now
oh Jesus I've watched the Luke Falk
games I didn't think it could get worse
and somehow Kirk Cousins qbr is slower
so I don't blame them
I don't know if they trade digs I I
don't know those guys though that should
be furious because they're getting
nothing right now they are completely
underachieving and they got a matchup
against the Giants secondary that they
should each see 10 targets in that game
minimum yeah it is gonna be fun to watch
because God the Buffalo Bills would die
right now to have Stefon Diggs so it
will be very telling to watch let's get
two blind
you mellow Rams at Seahawks Thursday
night if you're new to the show we
record on Thursday afternoon so we don't
get to watch the game but damn we want
to talk about it but it doesn't matter
because we already know what's gonna
happen that's how smart we are here at
stick to football and I'll tell you I'm
very impressed with the Seattle Seahawks
what they were able to do against the
Rams they're moving the ball very well
coming away with a big win here for
Seattle Russel Wilson looked amazing G
came at calf even showing up with a big
catch I like to see hawks I think they
might even have to be a favorite in the
NFC after this big win over the Rams and
I'll say my guy will dis Lee continues
to show out and I'm so glad that the
Seahawks won this week I was worried
about the Rams that I'm glad to see
always got a gun good to see Kris Carson
rebound after a little bit of an
inconsistent start but man I like the
Rams maybe we got on them a little bit
too early the Super Bowl hangover looks
pretty real for Shaun McVeigh and and
really anyone who's coached under Shaun
McVeigh his disciples are all struggling
right now and and we see it again
Seattle is a tough place to play you
don't take anything away from that but
it's good to see dis land Carson really
get rolling on offense yeah another week
on the tariff for Jared Goff the sack
numbers are up for him this Rams
offensive line has you know not being
great in pass protection but he's
holding on to the ball too long and
after a really slow week against Arizona
a vulnerable group it was ICD K Metcalfe
had that really nice deep catch down the
field and get him back on the fantasy
radar so Seattle this division is wide
open after Thursday Night Football week
six of the college football seasons here
we are almost to the halfway point of
college football and that is it's
depressing a little bit let's jump right
into the pics Melo and I are tied at 20
and 10 Connor who's a week behind us is
at 14 and 6 someone smarter than me can
do the math there but we're doing okay
we're up on the year number 14 Iowa at
number 19 Michigan Michigan is favored
by three and a half over/under forty
seven and a half guys I'm taking Iowa
and I'm taking the points I don't think
Michigan can score I know I always been
not great this year they've actually
struggled I think a lot I think they get
it going this week we see AJ up in essa
finally get into the backfield get more
than the 1 sack he's had this year and I
think Nate Stanley is gonna show that
he's a better quarterback prospect than
Shea Patterson if there's still any
doubt about
I think the hawkeye's role I'm gonna
agree with you here I think that Iowa's
gonna win this game too but I'll tell
you if Iowa wins this game we really
start we have to talk about Jim Harbaugh
because if you're losing games to the
Big Ten West in the big house that's not
a great sign and I know Iowa's looked
great this year so far I know that
they're ranked higher but Michigan is
still the favorite here three and a half
points if Michigan loses this game it's
gonna get bad the fan base is really
gonna start to get pissed off yeah I
think the one saving grace is that maybe
we see McCaffrey play a little bit more
quarterback I know I've been waiting for
it I know the Michigan fans have been
waiting for it but I'm gonna agree with
you here man I think Iowa wins this game
in the big house yeah Iowa for me all
the way I actually got when this opened
it was at four and a half so I put a
real life bet on Iowa I know they're on
the road at a tough place to play but I
just like their football team better
than Michigan right now simple as that
yep they are tougher and sometimes
that's just what it's all about number
seven Auburn - two and a half at Florida
your over-under is 48 and a half I don't
understand this line
I don't think Kyle Trask has been
terrible but I also don't think he's
been that good the Auburn defensive line
should should completely control this
football game I think we say we see
Perrin and all of the Florida offense
really get shut down this week by
Derrick Brown by Nick Coe I'm kind of a
bow Nick's believer I think all Byrne
could score enough points to cover this
spread and get the win I might go on the
under forty eight and a half seems a
little high in this one yeah I'll tell
you I've been back and forth on this
game it feels like a million times
I could see Florida winning this game
with Kyle Trask at quarterback I
actually like him probably more than
Felipe Franks which isn't saying a whole
lot but I think that he's got potential
he's been moving the ball very well he's
athletic he's a big guy too
I would not be surprised at all if
Florida wins this game at home but I do
think you're right it's very hard to bet
against that Auburn defensive line
because until they really get tested
when they see a school like LSU or
Alabama I think that they're gonna roll
over opponents because they can shut
down the run and they can get after the
quarterback and if you can do those two
things it's very hard to score the
football that's a little coaching 101
for you guys there so I'm gonna agree
with you I'm taking Auburn on the road
very tough to win in Gainesville but I
think the Auburn can do it
yeah 48 and 1/2 seems a little high I
think this is gonna be a defensive game
all around I don't have much belief in
either of these offenses right now
considering they are top 10 teams I'm
going with Auburn all the way I think
they have the better group on the
defensive line that makes the difference
I think this weekend we start to see
some separation in these top 10 teams
and that that's one game that'll do it
number 25 Michigan State has to play in
Columbus Ohio at 5:00 I don't know how
the [ __ ] they're number five Ohio State
- 24 the Buckeyes over/under 48 and a
half
take the over take the points Ohio State
is going to crush Michigan State and I
like Michigan State I like Joe Bochy I
like Kenny willikers but my god Justin
fields is unstoppable
this is a great scouting game I do think
the Ohio State is gonna win but this is
the best defense that Justin Fields has
seen so far they should be very solid on
Michigan State's and so we'll see what
they can do i do think that Ohio State
wins this one pretty easily
Ohio State alone might put up 48 and a
half points so I'm gonna smash that
other gonna score a half as well I mean
they will probably get to 49 would not
be surprised at all so I'm taking Ohio
State I'm taking the over in this one
should be at least a fun game to scout I
don't know that Michigan State has
anybody that can stop chase young so
good luck putting up points you
struggled against Arizona State right
now you have to face the best offensive
player in the nation yeah Michigan
State's front seven they can stop the
run game so this game is gonna be put in
the hands of Justin fields getting out
of the pocket and throwing the ball but
I have no concerns there they'll be fine
Ohio State all the way Cal at number 13
Oregon I think over I think Oregon is
overrated
this is minus 18 over just at 46 I
actually don't either and I was started
to say this to you guys before the show
I'm picking Oregon but I could see this
being an upset because I think Cal's
defense is very underrated you know I
think Oregon's offense is very overrated
so keep an eye on this game as a
potential upset I don't have the nuts to
pick Oregon as Melo likes to say but I
wouldn't be shocked if Cal wins and I
think this is gonna be a close game I'm
gonna roll with the Ducks here because I
love their offensive line still I think
they can win despite Justin Herbert in
this game
because I do think there's gonna be some
turnovers I really like the Cal defense
you guys talked about the linebacker
that they have earlier who's like has a
million tackles is it Weaver Weaver I
always get him and we all take I get
mixed up in Woodward but I do think this
is gonna be a close game I would
probably take the under and there's no
way in hell Oregon wins this by 18 yeah
I feel like a coward for picking Oregon
in this game but I do think they win I
just can't get over this line of 18
points we're out here saying that organ
is gonna beat this cow that's bent the
defense has been very very impressive by
two touched it
two touchdowns and two field goals
almost three touched like what where is
this number from and if they cover it I
mean good for them I'm betting against
that last leg organ yeah last one number
15 Washington - 16 and a half at
Stanford God Stanford has fallen this
year the over/under is 51 and a half
Jacob Eason has been close to perfect
this year Stanford they do have our guy
Paulson and Tebow a corner that's gonna
be a nice little matchup to see those
two but I think Eason probably just
avoids him all game we've seen the arm
talent for him the only question I have
about this one is it's on the road it's
in palo alto that could be a very tough
place to play I still love David Shaw
but I'm picking Washington I would just
stay away from the line in this one I
don't feel like this is one of those
games you bet on yeah I'm gonna take
Washington but I don't think it's gonna
get out of hand right not to 16 and a
half I do think that we might see two
touchdown difference here or a
double-digit win from Washington but
they have one great player this year and
that's Paulson daddybo and he plays
corner scheme around him don't throw it
in his side of the field
run away whatever you have to do you can
take him out of the ballgame it's not
like he's a linebacker or rush end or
anything like that so I am gonna take
Washington I do want to see Jacob Eason
he's not playing at midnight here
Central Time so that'll be a nice look
for Washington in the Huskies
yeah I think this Washington secondary
is the real deal and they should eat the
Stanford passing game alive now what I
will say is the only defense we've seen
Easton struggle against this year was
Cal so can Justin Herbert step it up and
have a big game against a defense that
has you know fare well against a pro
prospect I don't know but it'll be very
interesting to see in terms of this game
Washington rolls all the way right
or Stanford all right boys we all agreed
on these five games which is kind of
boring so let's spice it up a little bit
here the super underdog locksmith game
of the week to bet your money on because
I don't have the nuts to bet my own
money on I'm going Cincinnati over your
favorite school UCF hood the national
champions they're playing on Friday
night in Cincinnati I don't know if you
gentlemen have had the chance to look at
that Cincinnati football field they
painted that [ __ ] black yeah
they're gonna get a blackout in
Cincinnati
I like their odds cool weather Florida
team coming up to Ohio I like Cincinnati
put your money on it I don't have any
money
I don't have the nuts to do it but you
should we are gonna spice up your top
five this week you're gonna get the top
five rookies so far in the NFL season
but we wanted to go a little bit farther
than just yelling five names at you
we're gonna call out ourselves a little
bit here yes put the nuts on the table
and say hey these are the top rookies
and this is where we had them graded so
a little bit of accountability time here
at stick to football I'll kick us off
with my top five guys we're gonna go
five through one I don't know if we
talked about that before the show but
here we go number five for me Josh Allen
drafted by the Jacksonville Jaguars I
had him at number three overall I think
he's been everything that they hoped
that he could be so far this year a
weapon really in all three phases of the
game which is what we saw at Kentucky
he's getting after the quarterback he's
making tackles I I look at him and I
wonder how the hell the Oakland Raiders
drafted Cleveland fur all over him who's
been very very quiet so far this year so
I think we've only seen the best to come
for Josh Allen he looks really really
good so I feel like that when I got
pretty pretty right on number four I got
Brian burns who just won Defensive
Rookie of the Month for September he has
looked fantastic
I had him 17th overall so maybe a little
bit early on him or a bit a little bit
low excuse me on Brian burns respective
to how good he's looked so far the speed
the length the hand usage they're all
there for him and his lean build has not
been the issue that I really thought it
would be that was my my only question
mark about him was did he have the power
to make an impact in the NFL he
definitely has chase oneof itch the guy
who I gave my Rookie of the Month vote
to on the Wednesday show he has three
sacks
year I had a round to grade on win
ovitch and someone who I should have
moved up especially after our interview
with him because I really loved his
mentality he tested okay but not great
and I think that honestly like what got
in my head was I felt like he had so
much talent around him that maybe some
of those guys were scheming him open
you know like defenses would focus on a
Rochon Gary and Devin Bush and he kind
of got left at times but his production
so far albeit in like a rotational role
has been very very impressive he looks
like a steal for the New England
Patriots where they got him in round
three that picked 77 overall number two
the man the mustache Gardner Minshew I
had a round sixth grade on this dude
just did not think that I can actually
read my scouting report I said that he
had great leadership great character
great intelligence but he was small and
didn't have a big enough arm to ever be
more than like maybe a spot starter in
the league he has outperformed that as
we said earlier in the show his passer
rating is record-setting for a player in
their first four games he has looked
tremendous and then the number one
player scary Terry McClaren I had a
round too great on him but I had a low
round too great not like pick 33 or
anything but he has been he's been a
vision man and I'd like to parish
Campbell more than him if you told me or
asked me a month ago hey which Ohio
State receiver looks better so far I
would have said Paris Campbell it's who
I would have put my money on but Terry
has just been special getting open down
the field sucks he's a little bit banged
up now
hopefully we see him bounce back from
that quickly because I think he's
probably your frontrunner well no
Gardner man should we get Rookie of the
Year because you please quarterback but
McLaren will be your Offensive Rookie of
the Year right now yeah and that's why
I'll start with my list here a lot of
the same guys only one difference I'm
going Brian burns at number five I
really liked him coming out of Florida
State I love this edge class that we had
last year I had him as the number five
edge rusher though I thought Montez
sweat I like clean land furrow a lot
better both Allen I really liked all
those guys but I was a little bit low on
him but I still really liked him even at
picks 17 here I was on board with that
pick and he has outperformed because I
remember watching his early tape at
Florida State me like this guy probably
weighs too
25 that's not gonna play in the NFL but
he put on weight and he plays well with
it too a lot of guys can come into the
combine they'll put on weight so they
can weigh in they won't run he's held up
very well with this weight he's playing
great two and a half sacks already so
he's at number five for me chase Widow
vich we all should have been higher on
him I think we flirted a couple times
with putting him in the first round with
some of our mock drafts you know turns
out he probably should have went there
just 30 second overall to the Patriots
they shouldn't have waited for him
but he has played outstanding he's a
perfect fit for that scheme and what
he's doing I think that he's a guy who's
gonna keep playing at a high level with
the Patriots and I love what he's doing
next guy for me I'm going Devin Busch
who I had his linebacker number two
right behind Devin white I love his
athletic ability and after the first
week or two in Pittsburgh it kind of
looked like maybe he wasn't ready for
the NFL level it but I really think that
this is catching on for him now he looks
a lot better in coverage he's leading
all rookies and tackles I believe I
should probably double check that but I
really like the fit here with Devin Bush
I like the way that he played at
Michigan I think he's gonna fit in just
fine
with the picks Pittsburgh Steelers
number two for me it's got to be scary
Terry I loved him coming out of Ohio
State I remember seeing him at the
Senior Bowl everybody was talking about
Isabella everybody was talking about
that penny Hart and these are gonna be
great exceptional slot guys and it was
like wait a second who's this guy who's
dominating because we're not talking
about him enough and it was scary Terry
McLaren who has been exceptional the
Redskins pick him up in the second round
looks like a genius pick right now
hopefully he does get healthy because
when he is on the field he looked like
with their number one receiver he had
five catches 125 yards in his first NFL
game five catches 62 in the next with a
touchdown
six catches for 70 yards in his third
game touchdown in every game I hope he
gets healthy him and Dwayne Haskins
working together could be very
impressive because they already have
that camaraderie that timing and number
one for me I'm going with Gardner
Minshew this team needed a quarterback
we talked about it all offseason and
they got one with pick 199 which is a
pretty special draft place especially
when you're replacing a veteran
quarterback who took his team to a Super
Bowl and now injured I think I've heard
this story but
or I just don't recall it but I love
what Gardner man she's doing we will see
if he can hold up overtime or if this is
just a flash in the pan once people get
some tape on him defensive coordinators
might learn how to shut him down or he's
just going to keep bawling out like he
has been so Gardner Minshew number one
for me probably is gonna win Offensive
Rookie of the Year yeah he's been
insanely impressive so impressive that I
actually left him off the top five
because I think he is the undisputed top
rookie so far I think it's a little
easier when you're statistically to lead
the pack as a quarterback so Gardner
would be my undisputed number one I
actually had him in this late late sixth
round so
he's blowing away expectations but
number five for me on my non quarterback
list chasing winning [ __ ] I actually
got him right in there at 32nd overall I
like Matt said enjoy talking to him so
much just thought he was very athletic
on film he's been very good so far
already three sacks and in New England I
love what chase wina vich could do and I
think he's gonna be a part of their
defense for a very long time and number
four this is an underrated one Hollywood
Brown actually has more receiving yards
than scary Terry already but there's
only so many targets on the table that
week they beat the Dolphins I think he
played eight snaps because they they
don't want him to get hurt again they
don't want to run him into the ground
I love the steps Lamar Jackson has taken
this year but he's not this top five
pocket passer in the NFL right now where
Hollywood Browns gonna get all those
targets so for Hollywood he's been
phenomenal already the amount of
receiving yards that he's had Deven Bush
like Melo said a slow start but Deven
Bush for me at 3 after that Monday Night
Football game where he looks phenomenal
he's been a tackling machine
he is the guy now that the Steelers
traded up for because he just need to
get his feet wet a little bit and get
comfortable in the middle of that
defense handle a lot of rolls but he's a
great player is such a reliable
linebacking presence in the middle that
can blitz really well that we saw Monday
night so I loved Evan Busch and he's
only gonna get better throughout this
season number two for me Brian burns I
had him ninth overall I Devin Bush
eighth overall and I should have said
I'd Hollywood Brown 35th overall so you
can kind of see these were all guys that
were in that top 40 that teams are
getting instant returns and there's been
a lot of guys in the top 40 that teams
having Quinn and Williams has been hurt
Cleveland Farrell hasn't been that
seven White's been hurt so it's nice to
see these guys contributing like Brian
burns who just was the Defensive Rookie
of the Month top ten player for me
great pass rusher I think if you don't
get your hands on him he'll beat you
because he's so quick he could bend it
his size like Melo said he put on the
weight to play at the next level as a
three down player and the instant
returns have been great
number one for me I had scary Terry 68th
overall and I think you can make the
argument right up there with Gardner
Minshew
that he's been the best rookie so far I
know missing a game sucks not only for
him but for the stats but for how much
he has outperformed the giraffe's lot
that he was taken in he's in an awful
situation there were a ton of receivers
drafted ahead of him I think scary Terry
looks like the real deal whether it's
winning verticaly winning underneath we
know he can contribute on special teams
he is a great player and he's somebody
that I feel like I really didn't value
enough in this year's class it's early
like it's too early to say like oh we
missed on Yannick Lauren cuz I had him
at item 66 so it's I think it's too
early to say that but it's not too early
to learn lessons and I can't remember if
I said this on the podcast or if I just
said it to Melo my my scouting
resolution this year is to not let
anyone talk me off my spot with guys
because there were so many players that
happened to me last year like I would
have an opinion about a guy and then
Scouts would be like no no no no no like
here are all the reasons why and you're
like wina [ __ ] was one he was one
because I I don't want to say like oh I
had him so high but I I had him pretty
high until til scouting you know like
Scouting Combine season so that is my
resolution this year I aim for
transparency with this show and with
everything I do it's like no more no
more letting Scouts talk me on my
spot-on guy so those are our top five
rookies and also where we evaluated them
let's take a break when we come back
we're gonna close this out with some
draft on draft draft on draft time and
this is a great question TM our troopers
wants to know do you think the current
Alabama wide receiver group will have a
better NFL career than the 2012 Clemson
group that was a load of room with Sammy
Watkins DeAndre Hopkins martavis Bryant
Adam Humphries dron browning
even sure on peak I think yes yeah and I
think what's it's sets them apart you
look at the Alabama group they might
have three receivers right now in this
draft class go round one they might have
three to four receivers on this team
that are number one targets for an NFL
team I truly believe that Judy will be a
number one receiver on which everyone
drafted I also think Henry rugs will be
I really like what he's doing at Alabama
I think that a lot of people were just
taking it in
Judy and looking at him but rugs is
legit and guess what Devon chase Smith
he's coming on strong to where I told
people he's probably like a second or
third round here I did a mock draft on
my own I had him in the first round it's
I think he's gonna accelerate his draft
stock I think that he's gonna get a lot
more targets apparently very good at
rock-paper-scissors right and then
sophomore true sophomore Jalen Waddell
he could be another guy who's a number
one receiver at the NFL level I don't
think we've ever seen anything like what
we're seeing at Alabama that Clemson
group was special Sammy Watkins very
high draft pick but I still think he's a
number two receiver at best even after
having a great week one this year and
playing for my Kansas City Chiefs but I
still think that this Clemson group had
one true number one DeAndre Hopkins who
might be the best receiver in the Nate
in the league right now but you look at
Alabama they might have four I should
probably take a look at a freshman that
they brought in because that is a
specialist yeah Miche
they love ya John michi they believe
that he's like the next one I think it's
easily Alabama because like I've I've
said Judy's the if it's nice if he's not
the best receiver I've ever evaluated
it's Julio Jones and they're they're
really just different species of wide
receiver
like you said Melo Sammy Watkins I love
Sammy he was my top receiver in that
class he has not performed up to being
the number four pick in the draft and a
player that a team traded up very highly
for so know and like martavis bryant i
was a flash in the pan but he couldn't
stay on the field so i don't think it
would be that hard for these alabama
guys to have better careers than that
clemson group there's a lot of big names
it's not a lot of production and they
might not live up to the DeAndre Hopkins
but I do think that as a floor you
look at rugs and judy i think they will
at least be Sammy Watkins in the NFL
yeah I'm not ready to say that anyone
will be Hopkins but I think collectively
especially when you do mix in somebody
that's not draft eligible like Waddell
that that Alabama room right now as a
collective will be better than that
Clemson group and I think you almost
have to weigh it against the current
Clemson group because I think t Higgins
and Justin Ross can be NFL number one
wide receivers they're absolutely
phenomenal so I look at Judy he's really
good
I'm not gonna get into the game that a
lot of people are right now is Judy even
the best receiver on his own team oh yes
come on yes I almost [ __ ] thing I've
ever I loved rugs you know I love what
we've seen from Smith they're great
players they're not Judy there and watch
watch team sell out against Judy at
times they know they're like we're not
gonna let this guy beat us because he
beat everyone else that let him so when
it comes down to it for me I think the
Alabama group will be better than that
Clemson group the real question is will
anyone be as good as Hopkins and the guy
that has a chance is Judy here's the
thing I I'm gonna go down a rabbit hole
because that pisses me off Devon to
Smith that had a great game mm-hmm I
don't think Devon to Smith is a great
wide receiver yet like meadow said he
has the potential to become one Jerry
Judy one the blitek off last year when
dudes were breaking catch records he was
still like he had 68 catches their this
is by far the best receiver in college
football
hands down yeah you know these guys are
getting looks they're getting targets
because people know you have to shut
down Jerry Jude you're gonna have to
bracket him over the top he's taking two
defenders he's very special
he doesn't have rugs of speed but rugs
doesn't have that route running into
control of his hips and the hands that
judy has it's a very special group you
can like all of them yes that's that's a
little insider trick there yeah you can
actually like more than one player right
Jeremy Godin wants to know when it comes
to building a defense what do you feel
needs to be the strongest part the front
seven or the secondary so I actually
thought a lot about this today because I
don't everything else to do I think it
is easier to find pass rushers than it
is to find corners it's like to find a
great pass rusher it
not to say that it's easy but I feel
like it's an easier scouting process of
like guess what chase young is really
good I like finding corners even when
you can identify them correctly they
just don't come along very often look at
last year the only other corner drafted
in the first round was a Andre Baker and
he's looked like [ __ ] so far this year
so I think it's harder to find a good
corner I would rather have a great
secondary that can cover for six seconds
and let me manufacture a pass rush like
New England I'll throw third-round picks
like chase win a [ __ ] at you all throw
undrafted free agents like Rob nicob in
chat you all day long or Kyle van Noy
who the Detroit Lions didn't want I feel
like you can find athletes who can get
after the quarterback if your coverage
is good enough yeah I agree with you and
I coach secondary so I love the safety
position and I think if you're looking
at this from an NFL standpoint I
actually think the secondary is more
important because like you said it is a
little bit easier to maybe find guys
that you can plug and play at the edge
rusher position you can mix them up with
getting some D tackle pressure and
things like that so I'm gonna say in the
NFL it's just so pass happy that the
secondary is probably going to be the
more important maybe I'm a little bit
biased there because I love safeties I
think with the way the rules are I go
the other way I would rather have a
great front seven I just think even the
great corners in today's NFL can't play
the position the way they should be
allowed to they'll get flagged they'll
get beat eventually it's just the way
the games designed I'd rather have the
premier pass I would rather let's ask it
like this would you rather have Khalil
Mack or Jalen Ramsey I don't know I'd
rather I'll call you Mack yeah I like I
mean I love both like whoever you think
the top corner is I just think I for me
I'd rather have the premier pass rusher
because now they get called for roughing
the quarterback non-stop so it's almost
evening out at this point you can't
write any defense I just think you can't
play any pass defense anymore all right
let's switch it up a fun one it is
spooked Ober as I like to call it the
rookie season rookies Jeremy Brown wants
to know what is the scariest movie of
all time
I'm a scary movie like nerd I love scary
movies like if like whether it's with my
kid or
my girlfriend like that's what we do we
watch the scary movies him it is five
years old seen The Shining he was in it
yeah he walks trying going Red Rum I
think I have two answers for this I
don't I feel like old scary movies
aren't scary you know it's like The
Exorcist is [ __ ] up but it's not scary
the one movie that I've seen recently
that actually like affected me was the
strangers because that [ __ ] could happen
like I don't need scary people in like
burlap sacks the scariest line in that
movie is like I don't even remember
because I've watched it once and it was
years ago and they're like why would you
do this because you were home exactly
that [ __ ] locked up yeah that's a good
one and then insidious was really scary
too
I don't think I saw that one got bad
like it got like hokey the first one was
good yeah that was like in one of my
reply okay and a lot of people were
saying hereditary that movie was dumb I
haven't seen any of these I'll tell you
the trailers scared the [ __ ] out of me I
even painted out Wednesday night I say
I'm feeling brave
give me a scary movie nope washes
trailers like I'm not ready
why not breathe my daughter tried
telling me hereditary like the scariest
movie ever so we watched it we're right
when it came out we rented it at home I
turned it off halfway through I was like
this movies dump really like it's just
and I don't turn movies off I'll watch
anything I will throw out two that we're
not paid by Netflix the haunting of Hill
House a great series that's scary yeah
it's not scary though there are scary
parts there are jumpy parts and then we
started watching it this French show
Mary Anne and it's good so lady tweeted
that one M yeah it's really good so
those are my night of the Maddy Miller
I would like to disagree you know the
first time I saw The Exorcist and maybe
it was because I was young that movie
scared the [ __ ] out of me who were like
six years old yeah it was very when she
starts masturbating with the cross like
that shouldn't you say that on a podcast
I'm not a big scary movie guy but my
favorite and I don't think it's scary
but it's a great movie would be the
shining I thought the saw all the Saw
movies were pretty good eventually got
old after
four and five it's like how many times
can we do this but man you guys keep up
with a lot more than me I don't know
yeah that's that's what we have people
go on hayrides and they watch scary
movies yeah
now we grew up watch them I remember
being five years old watching Nightmare
on Elm Street and not being able to
sleep for like a week and my mom telling
our dad like maybe we shouldn't have
done that yeah that was a baby that
looks good oldie but a goodie goodie at
turps two for three who's the best
college player who never played it down
in the NFL
oh wow the first one that comes to mind
for me is Tommie Frazier because I've
talked about him before that was like
the first guy that was like holy [ __ ]
college football is awesome so I would
say Tommie Frazier or Charlie Ward
because I think that he was a little bit
before his time dude was a basketball
star for Connors Knicks I really would
have liked to see what he could have
done in the NFL I know that he was
probably a little bit short for the
position and people weren't ready for
that at the NFL you had to be like six
five to thirty it just wasn't that time
I really liked Charlie Ward at Florida
State
I liked him as a Knick even so Heisman
winning quarterback I would have loved
to have seen him play and so I I wanted
to say like oh Scott frost
but he was actually drafted Eric Crouch
was drafted as well you took two good
ones how Jeff Samardzija oh yeah into
the right answer he was a great game I
thought he could have been a first round
receiver oh yeah but but then decided to
be a pitcher and make a hell I loved him
at Notre Dame I hate him he was awesome
yeah I Notre Dame like he he caught
everything he did oh my god Samardzija
was great and he's kind of tailed off I
know he had a good bounce-back season
this year but he got that giant contract
and yeah it was just kind of average he
made the right decision though he did he
definitely did and a lot of people were
hating on that decision at the time they
thought he should play football yeah
yeah so many great questions there you
know a random fact did you know that
Billy Beane was recruited by Stanford to
replace John Elway but he was drafted in
the first round by the Mets and played
baseball instead yeah he's a great high
school quarter
he should have went to Stanford career
probably would really different man he
you'd like you're getting recruited
replace John [ __ ] away well he drafts
better than John away does this for day
I find a better quarterback than John Oh
bad maybe you should cross and on a
discount budget Andrew Magnuson with our
last question the 2020 draft class is
loaded with offensive skill players out
of the quarterbacks running backs and
receivers which position do you expect
to see the most shake up near the top
between now and April I don't think
there will be a change at my top
quarterback or wide receiver and it
running back I have Swift and tailored
time yeah me it's wide receiver by a
mile I can see like two through seven
changing right that's back to i'm pretty
solid on - uh I have Swift and Taylor
tied and then Judy I want to see what
happens with starting at position number
two really because that's where the
shake-up is I guess you can call that at
the top the number one guys are pretty
locked in right now I don't think you're
changing Higgins team really like CD
lamb yep great I was watching him the
other day he reminds me of John Ray
Hopkins that's why yes well yeah I was
watching him so and somebody I was like
I can't get a cup for this guy and
somebody said AJ Green and it made me
like Higgins more they're about the same
size
yeah but CDs not I guess he's like just
built differently than nuke he is he's a
little bit slender well he's like six
foot one eighty five probably 189 okay
so a little bit bigger well fill out his
hands the catch that he made against I
think he was UCLA last year on the
sidelines that was I mean Odell Beckham
he's he's got some hands I think he's
faster than what he looks running very
fast yeah he looks like a four five five
kind of guy yeah
so that might hold it hold him back
especially if you're only weighing in at
189 but I do really like him I'm down on
ylvis' cachet Knoll are you it well he's
got a shitty quarterback I think like I
think the hype just got out of control
that was probably my fault okay
appreciate I really like him but they
just they use him in a lot of different
gadgety ways to get him the ball with
like jet sweeps curry like Stephen
Montessori minute Wildcat I think that
he's gonna have to really
how to run routes in the NFL but he's so
athletic he's so big people even
comparing him to Julio Jones if you look
at the right places so I like che Nolt a
lot I like Higgins I like lamb this
receiver group is gonna be very special
don't forget about tyler johnson henry
rugs i'm probably the best receiver at
alabama I have a Chanel hot take I would
move into running back he he's six two
so he's just short enough just one more
inch and you're not playing running back
but man he's when he's so good with the
ball in his hands he is I don't know if
he's that fast I think I think he is
kick returns show that all right good
punt return I mean he's running away
from play people he's a probably a long
Strider I really think that he's one of
the best athletes in this class even if
it doesn't show up in the 40 I think it
will on tape that's I guess I said I
don't know if his 40 will be great I I
agree he's agile his change of
directions really good I don't know what
his forte will be all right that's a
weird wide receiver discussion to end
the show with well that's how we do it
Monday will be just me and Melo coming
to you from Arrowhead where the last
time we were there I ended up in the ER
expensive expensive cab ride forever
telling that story eleven thousand
dollar cab ride but it was fun I was on
a stretcher doing the hook em horns and
you put a price tag on that okay you
can't $11,000 yeah yeah they cut my
Chiefs hoodie off me I was nervous
buying a new one like please don't makes
their yeah probably so alright that is
our show we'll talk to you Monday
morning
live from Arrowhead